A
lot of my work is about resilience. I've written about
it in a whole range of contexts. I wrote about it among artists who were responding to the Soviet Union.
I wrote about it in the context of a fat book about
depression. And having been so interested in resilience and so interested in art,
I was fascinated to think about a place where there was no art. And under the
Taliban in Afghanistan there was no art at all. And
so I decided that I would go there
immediately after the American invasion and see what happened after the Taliban
had fallen.
Now there are arguments to be made that if you are gay and Jewish
with an anxiety disorder and a tendency toward
depression a field trip to war-ravaged Afghanistan
may not be incredibly sound
judgment. And there were those who tried to discourage me, but
I went. And when I got there, I thought, 'this is a
whole new level of anxiety,' and I thought, 'but at
least, at least I've got my story to do.' So, my first port of call
was the U.N. because that was sort of the center of everything that was happening, and I went... and I met with someone at the U.N. and
I
said, "I've come, I'm doing a story. The New York Times agreed to send me, and I'm going to write about
the resurgence of art in Afghanistan following the fall of the Taliban." I said, "And you've been
living here for some time." I said, "Do you know any artists?" And he
said, "There are no artists in Afghanistan." And
I said, "Oh." I said, "Well...
maybe some poets? Or some musicians? And he said, "There are no poets
in Afghanistan," he said, "but there's someone downstairs
whose sole job, actually, has been to look at the music of Afghanistan and in fact, try to get it out into the world and he'd probably know
know all about the musicians, so, if you just go downstairs, you could talk to him, and I imagine
he'll be able to help you." And I thought, that would be great because while I could just
about imagine a world without film and
without photography and without acting and without poetry and without
any kind of figurative visual art, I
couldn't really imagine a country without music - a country where it had
been illegal for a mother to hum to her child. People had been
arrested for that. A country where it's illegal even to clap. And so
I went downstairs
to the man who'd come to study music in Afghanistan, and I did my little patter song, and I said I
was there to write about all of these things, and I said, "Now, I wonder, you've been studying this," I said, "Can
you tell me about some musicians in Afghanistan?" And he said,
"There is no music in Afghanistan." And I thought, 'I've
come quite a long
way to get the story of how there is actually no art or music
in Afghanistan. And fortunately I had a translator with me,
my translator Farooq, who was and
is an amazing friend, and who had trained as a doctor under the Taliban.
Which meant that each day he had eight hours of instruction:
seven hours of religious instruction, and one hour of
medical instruction. And he felt that he didn't really know enough to be a doctor,
and had decided to be a translator for a while while he tried to educate himself. And
Farooq said to me, "You
know, I don't know much about the things you're interested in," he said, "but, there
is actually a museum in Kabul. It's small, but it's the National Gallery
of
Afghanistan, and they're sort of re-opening it later today,
and we could probably get into that, if you wanted to go." And I said, "I would
definitely like to
go." And we went off to the museum, and we went
in, and on the walls of the museum there were a lot of empty
landscapes. And, of course, the Taliban had said that the representation of the human
figure or even of animals was contrary to Islamic law, a debatable point, but one that they had
held. And it turned out that there was an artist, Dr. ??Asifi??,
who had, when the Taliban came to power, gone into the museum at night with
a set of watercolors, and he had painted over all of the figures
within the
paintings. And when we got there, Dr. Asifi
was there. And he had a bucket of water, and he had a piece of cloth, and Karzai,
who seemed like the great hope at that point, had come for this opening as well, and the electricity kept going out
the way it did everywhere in Kabul that winter. And Dr. Asifi carried his
bucket, and he dipped his piece of cloth in, and he began to rub the surface
of one of the paintings, and
suddenly, everything began to appear. The figures came out. The
animals came out. What the painting was about came out, and everyone
burst into
applause. And Dr. Asifi said to me that he had a friend
who was the greatest painter of miniatures. The Persian miniature is an art that began
in Herat, and the Afghans, therefore, claim it as their own. And he said, "Go and see this
guy who does the
miniatures." And there was no phone system in Afghanistan at that point, and there was no postal
system, and there were certainly no fax or e-mail, and the only way to see anyone was to
go and show up where they were. So I got the address of this other artist and I went off to
see
him. And he showed me these exquisite miniatures that he was painting. And I said, "They're
very, very beautiful." I said, "But they seem, they seem very,
very traditional." And I said, "Are you introducing any kind of innovation?" And
he said
to me, "Ah," he said, "You come from the West, where the past is safe,
and so you can make things that are about the future, but for those of us
in Afghanistan, whose past has been very nearly annihilated, we have to
secure the past before we can even begin to think about the future."
And he said to me, "If you want to understand these feelings," he said, "I do know a poet who has gone
back to writing secular poetry. You should go and see him." And, so, the
next day we went to see the poet, and we showed up at his house. And he showed me some of his poems
one of which said,
"On the highest escarpment, on the sharpest peak
inscribe this epitaph of the futureless generation: That instead of mother's milk
we were given guns. And instead of education
we were given war.
Don't blame us. We could do nothing for you."
And he said to me, "You should talk to other people who are writing and other people who are doing things."
And he gave me a few more names and addresses. And one of them, it was for a woman who
was doing poetry with some other women. And we went to their
house, and they agreed to come and meet with us, someplace else. And when they walked
in they were all wearing burkas,
And they took off the burkas, so that we could sit and talk, and they were incredibly sophisticated and cosmopolitan.
And I said, "The Taliban has fallen. Why are you still wearing that thing? Why
is everyone in Kabul still wearing those burkas?" And one of them said, "Well.
I'm wearing it because they might come back to power, and if they do,
they'll punish anyone who went out without one." And one of them said, "I'm wearing
this because if I get raped or beaten up, people
will say it was my own
fault." And then the third one, who was the poet, said,
"I always thought if the Taliban fell, I would burn this thing, and I would never put it on again.
But you know,
after five years, you get used to being invisible, and the prospect of
being visible again is very
overwhelming." She was the one who said to me, "There's a lot of music.
There's a lot
of music." And she said, "This is the best singer. You should go and see this man." And she gave
me his name and his address. And so the next day, we went to his house. And we arrived.
And he greeted us, and he was very warm, and we stood outside the house for a minute, and I said to him,
"You are a singer." I said,
"You couldn't sing for all of these years. You had no music at all." I said, "Didn't you go crazy?
Wouldn't one to go crazy, having no music at all?" And he said, "At the
beginning, I thought I would go crazy." He said, "But then I realized that there was
a kind of music that even the Taliban couldn't forbid." He said, "Come in." And we
walked into his house, and as we were walking in, he said, "A few months after they came to power
I went to the market and I bought twenty pigeons,
and I bought twenty doves, and they've lived in the house with me ever since." And we sat in
his room while these doves and pigeons
flew around us and circles. The room was a
mess. Um. And he said that was the music, and he
said, "If you're really interested in music." He said, "There's actually a
group of amazing musicians, who are really trying to bring back the great
Afghan classical tradition." He said "They practice most
afternoons in the basement of a building opposite the television tower. Go
there and hear what they're
doing." So that afternoon, Farooq and I went off to hear the other musicians.
And when we arrived, they were in this basement. It was cold in Kabul. It was
February. There was no heating anywhere. They were sitting there and they were playing with gloves on on
string instruments,
which, I must say, does not improve the
performance. Um. But nonetheless they were playing beautifully, and I sat, and I
watched them. And at the end of an hour,
they said, "You seem so interested." They said, "Do you have any questions for us?" And I said,
"If you weren't able to play for all those years, how did you remember these instruments and what to
do with them?"
And one of them said to me, "You know, we couldn't practice
in real life during the day, but I practiced every night in my dreams."
And then I said to one of them, "The instrument your playing - I know that's a traditional Afghan instrument. All
the instruments were supposed to be destroyed when the Taliban came to power. How did you keep it? And in good
shape
too?" And he said, "Oh yes, this is a Sarinda."
He said, "And what I did was, I had a wood pile behind the house, where I
kept all of the wood, and I put the Sarinda in the middle of the wood pile. And every few
days I'd bring in some more logs, or I'd take some logs away, and I'd rearrange it, and if you were only
looking at it from the end,
it could pass for scrap wood. And I knew that if any of my neighbors reported me,
I could get stoned to death." He said, "but it gave me such comfort to know it was there, in
the
pile." And then I said, "I've loved hearing your music." And they said, "But, you know, there are
only seven of us here today, and there are actually eleven in our group. We could get
the whole group together, if you want to hear us all play." And I said, "I would love that." And they
said, "Well, when do you want to do it?" And I said, "How about
Friday?" And they said, "Sure, Friday would be good." And I said,
"Afternoon? Five o'clock?" And they said, "Five o'clock would be great." And then I had a little inspiration, and
I said, "I'm happy to come back and hear you playing here again. I know this is where you
practice, but actually a group of journalists and I rented an old al-Qaeda house."
Which were the only houses that actually did have heating in Kabul at that point they
said, and, "Maybe you'd like to come and play someplace where you didn't have to have gloves on your
hands to play string
instruments." And they said, "That would be fantastic." And I said great, "So five o'clock
Friday. This is where I'm living. I'll see you then."
And then we left, and I thought, 'Wow. I have eleven musicians coming to play
in the house at five o'clock on Friday. And,' I thought,
'those poets we saw, and that other singer, we should invite them to come and hear these guys,
these guys are really
amazing.' And I thought, 'we should find the, the artists we saw.' And then
I thought 'And I'd love to invite Marla.' My friend Marla, the human rights activist who was
living down the block, and who was killed in Iraq, and who I miss. And I wanted to invite the
other journalists with whom I was sharing the house.
And I had to invite the man from the U.N. who had told me that there was no music in
Afghanistan. And I thought 'I'll just invite all the people I've met.' I had been there only a week,
but I had met a lot of people. And Farooq and I spent Thursday going around and inviting
people, and we invited everyone.
And there was a guy who cooked at the house where we were staying and I said to him, "There's going to be a bunch of people coming
on Friday. Could you by any chance provide some snacks for people?" And he said,
"I, I could make dinner, if you want me to."
And I said, "I, I don't think you could make dinner." I said, "There'll be eighty or ninety people coming here."
And he said, "Ohh," he said, "eighty or ninety." He said, "Well, the only way I
could make dinner for eighty or ninety people would be if I got an assistant, and I had money to buy
ingredients
and, you know, that's a big thing." And I said, "Well, I understand that." I said, "What would be involved in it?"
He said, "You know that would cost,
I mean, it could be a hundred fifty, it could be even two hundred dollars to do dinner for
90." And I said, "I'm going to spring for it."
And I said, "You go ahead and do that." And so the next day, it was Friday,
and at five o'clock the musicians arrived. And they sat down, and they began to play.
And it was so long since they'd had an audience and they'd had people who wanted to
listen. And the Afghans came, and the foreigners who I'd got to know came, and the
guy from the U.N. came, and everyone came. And there was this amazing buffet dinner.
I went to Afghanistan to do a piece for The New York Times, but after I returned,
I did a piece for 'Food & Wine'
magazine. Um.
But we sat there, and everyone ate. And the musicians were so enraptured by having us all
there, that they would get up one at a time to get some food or to do something, but they just
never stop playing, and they went on, and they played ,and they played. And the Afghans started showing the
rest of us how to do certain kinds of traditional dancing to the music. And we began
dancing. And they played. And we ate. And someone showed up with
a bottle of whiskey, which was strictly contraband in Afghanistan at that point. It was sort of like
being in tenth grade and having to someone show up at your party with a bag of
weed. And I taught Farooq in English, so he could teach, as
well as he could, in some relevant language everyone else. The word for "Hangover" which
was a word they had not previously
needed.
And they just went on playing. And the music seemed to get more beautiful the more
they played, and the more they played together. And it was warm. And it was glowing.
And there was a curfew in Kabul at ten o'clock, and you couldn't be in the streets past ten o'clock,
and so, at nine thirty I began saying
to people, "Do you, do you want to get home? It's gonna be 10 o'clock soon." I said it to the
musicians, and the musicians said, "Oh, it would take us an hour and a half to get home. We've missed the curfew.
We'll have to stay." And the guests started saying, "Oh, I can't leave
while this is happening." And the musicians went on playing. And the curfew,
was a curfew until dawn. And they played until six o'clock the following morning
without ever taking a break.
Thirteen solid hours of
music. And afterwards, I thought to myself that when I'd written
about depression I had said, there's a kind of joy which is possible only after
you've been profoundly
depressed. And I realized, there is a kind of music that is possible only after you've
been silent for 5
years. And that I had been the fortunate witness to those extraordinary sounds
and to that sacred and holy moment when the music began again.
I told Farooq a few days ago on SKYPE that I was going to tell this story, and
we had a long talk about it and went over some of the
details. And when we finished, Farooq, for whom I've tried to get a visa to come here,
now for almost ten years, Farooq said to me,
"I'm so glad that you will tell that story, and that people will be able to
remember the moment of hope, when the American invasion had just happened, and we were
so joyful and had such belief in what we thought was going to come." Thank
you.
[Applause]